Do you have what you say? A story worth telling? Is it important to hear it?
A local topic that deserves to be spread globally? YouTube and World Economic Forum open
Davos doors to one person, to a great thinker, to a fighter, is you. You can participate on the platform
With world leaders in a special committee devoted to your cause. Are you fighting for human rights?
For the environment? Against poverty? Whatever your case, this is your chance to stand and hear
Your voice . Only one person can join these. Someone who has passion
And estimated. His urgent issue needs world attention. Click on the word "Ricord" and submit your case
Upload the video on YouTube before January 4, 2010 so you get the chance to participate in Davos Forum discussions
For more details, visit www.youtube.com/Davos if you have the opportunity to change
The world you live in, what would it look like? a